EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE HEARING
EVERYONE ONE WE- ARE ALSO
REQUIRED TO MASTER THE ONE IF
YOU KNOW OF A MASSIVE VIOLENT
FOR YOU- AND AS FAR AS- WELL
ACTUALLY- 5H I'M
TESTIMONY IS THE USUAL OF
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM- MUST COMPLY
WITH ALL SOCIAL DISTANCING MASS
REQUIREMENTS ON THE ROOM THERE
IS ANYONE IN THE ROOM THAT
WOULD WANT TO TESTIFY WHEN WE
HEAR THE BILL. A MAJOR HANFORD
ALONG WITH THIS IS- WILL
MODERATE TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS COULD
TESTIFY. FOR CALLING IN TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT WE ARE
SO USED TO YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ON THE
BILL THE CALL IN NUMBER. FOR
THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AGAIN THAT'S EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN. FOR CALLING
EMPLOYEE PUT PLEASE PLAN TO DO
SO AS YOU OFFER THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON HAS BEEN IN THE
BILL PRESENTATION. WE ONLY HAVE
ONE BILL SO THAT WOULD MEAN
ONCE YOU START IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED PLEASE CALL IN.
OPERATE ONLINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE PLEASE OR
THE SUPPLIER OPPOSE A BILL. FOR
CALLING IMPLEMENT ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MEDIAN LIVESTREAM BROADCAST
YOUR SMART DEVICES REDUCES
SOUND DISTORTION. HE'S BE
ADVISED IF YOU'RE A MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
OR AGAINST A BILL YOUR MAN ON A
LIFELINE. I WANTED TO MEET
YOURSELF UNTIL YOU'RE CALLED ON
TO SPEAK- MADAM SECRETARY IF WE
CAN. HAVE THE ROLE TAKEN IN
ORDER TO ESTABLISH QUORUM
PLEASE. KALRA THERE WILL HAVE
BEEN SALAS JONES SAWYER. REYES
YEAH THEREFORE HERE ONE
ACCOMPLISHMENT NORTH SOLAR.
THAT IS ALL IN. CONTRAST YEAH.
A STEP DOWN SCRIPT- FOREVER.
AND WE. YEAH YEAH. THE.
PRESENCE AND THEN. SHARE
WHATEVER YOU'RE READY PERCENT
AB. FIFTEEN OH SIX- EIGHTY
FIFTEEN OH SIX IS AMEND IN THIS
TO ADDRESS. IS A ARE NONE YEAH.
I THINK SO THEY HAVE- WITH THE
MICROPHONE ON FOR THE PAST YEAR
WE SPOKE. OKAY. I'M HERE TO
PRESENT IT AS AN ADULT YOU KNOW
SIX WAS AMENDED IN THE SENATE
TO ADDRESS THE CURRENT
TEMPORARY EXEMPTION NEWSPAPER
CARRIERS IN THE ABC TEST FOR
EMPLOYMENT STATUS THIS BILL IS
THE RESULT OF A THOUGHTFUL
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE INDUSTRY
SPECIFICALLY THE NEWS PUT NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION. AS WELL
AS CONSULTATION FEEDBACK FROM
LABOR STAKEHOLDERS. AB FIFTEEN
OH SIX WORKS DOWN THE TEMPORARY
EXEMPTION FROM ABC TEST FOR
NEWSPAPER CARRIERS FOR THREE
YEARS SO THAT EXPIRES ON
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. THIS EXTENSION INCLUDES
CRITICAL REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
IN ORDER FOR THE STATE. AND
STAKEHOLDERS TO ASSESS THE USE
OF THE INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR
MODEL IN THE INDUSTRY.
UNDERSTAND ANY TRENDS IN
CARRIER MISS CLASSIFICATION.
AND ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH THE
LAW. BUT THIS BILL HAS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION IS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
SINCE AMENDED. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WILL NOW WE GOT WITH ONE
WITNESS IN SUPPORT- BRITNEY-
WE'RE SORRY ON THE PHONE
BRITNEY. MODERATELY PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THIRTY BY SAUDI- GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR THE COMPANIES THE-
WHERE HE SAID OF COURSE THE
CONDUCT OF. CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
A STRONG RECORD OF EIGHTY SIX
S. THANK MEMBER CALLED AS TO
THANK MEMBER KALRA STAFF AND
MANY MORE STAKEHOLDERS. TO HOW
BE COLDER CHáVEZ WORK ON BOTH
A CHINOOK AND WEBER OF OUR
FIFTY OF SIXTY. EXPAND IN THE
PAST CARE SIDE CAPERS. AND
BECAUSE TWENTY FIVE CALL
REQUIRING PARTY BECAUSE- FOR
TWENTY REQUIREMENTS THIS YEAR I
SINCERE STAR VERY OUT AND IT'S
GOING HIGH TO GET FROM THE
NUMBER AT STATE. TO LABOR. AND
OTHER RELIGIOUS TO DISCUSS.
DIVERS COMMITTEE ACROSS THE
STATE. MEDIA INCREDIBLY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT RECOGNITION
PUBLICATIONS THE BUDGET
CREDIBLE HARD TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ABOUT LOCAL
COVERAGE HE SAID HE SAID BACK
IN CENTERS. YEAH COUNTY
PROTOCOL DEMONSTRATIONS SCHOOL
DISTRICT TWENTY OPEN PLAN. AND
OTHER IMPORTANT NEWS. LAST YEAR
ONE PUBLICATIONS HAVE BEEN
INCREDIBLY HARD HIT HARD BY THE
LOSS OF APPETITE. AROUND 50%
COVERAGE AND BOB FIRE COVERAGE
OF THE BY A WALL TO HELP KEEP
CALIFORNIA. ABOUT FIFTY B.
FIFTY NOTHING. AND EXTENSION OF
THE BECAUSE EVERYTHING OF
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SHOWS THAT
MEERKAT CHRIS. WOULD OFTEN HAVE
WHAT TO GET POLITICAL BE MADE
FOR. SIX FOUR WAS ELEVEN.
DELIVERY AREA- AND CONSIDER
PRESS SAYS AND SEVENTY ONE
BECAUSE OF THE FORCE. HOFSTEDE
COST. OUR MEMBERS AND THE
GRATITUDE TO EVERYONE OPEN DATA
SEVEN QUITE PROBABLY THREE PM
TODAY STARTING MARGARET YOUR TO
MEN BECAUSE I'M SORRY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TEST AND
SO. ANYBODY IN THE AUDIENCE
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. C. N. NINE META
MODERATORS ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINES I WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN OH SIX.
THANK YOU COLONEL PHONE LINES
ARE ON THE CONFERENCE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
REMOVED OPPOSITION. IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE
LINES. KERN ONLINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND SEE NO
OPPOSITION IN THE CHAMBER- YEAH
I'LL MAKE A MOTION WITH THE
BILL ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE YEAH I JUST HAVE A
COMMENT I JUST WANT PEOPLE TO
BE REALLY CLEAR THAT- WHEN I
LAY OFF THIS BILL TODAY IT'S
NOT BECAUSE I HAVE SOMETHING
AGAINST OUR NEWSPAPER
DISTRIBUTORS AND CARRIERS ARE
ANY OF THE OTHER MERRY OUT OF
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS THAT
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THIS
EXERCISE. AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
AGAIN THE ISSUE I HAVE IS THAT
WE'RE NOT TAKING CARE OF THE
UNDERLYING PROBLEM WHEN YOU
FIND A BILL THAT DOES THIS MUCH
DAMAGE WE NEED TO ADDRESS THAT
NOT JUST CONTINUE THIS THIS
EXERCISE SO I'LL BE LAYING OFF
TODAY- BUT- THAT CERTAINLY IS
NO REFLECTION ON THE IMPORTANCE
THAT I FEEL THE NEWSPAPER
DISTRIBUTION CARRIERS HAVE
THANKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ELSE THINK GO SECOND
MISTER WARD. AS CHAIR WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- AND I AGREE THAT WE-
SHOULDN'T BE CONTINUE TO TURN
OUR WHEELS AND THAT'S WHAT
REALLY WHAT WHAT WAS HAPPENING
OVER THE LAST COUPLE YEARS- IT
WAS A PROCESS THAT THAT- I
WASN'T HAPPY WITH I DON'T
THINK- A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
COMFORTABLE WITH- AND THERE
WAS. LITTLE TO NO COMMUNICATION
WITH THE NEWSPAPER INDUSTRY.
AND MY OFFICE BUT THIS YEAR WAS
DIFFERENT- AND I THINK TO. A
SPECIALTIES POINT- WE THERE WAS
A GENUINE EFFORT. TO TRY TO
WORK TOGETHER TO- TO. FIGURE
OUT WHAT IF ANYTHING COULD BE
DONE. IN TERMS OF GETTING THE
DATA THAT FRANKLY- WE'VE BEEN
ASKING FOR- BUT I'VE BEEN
ASKING FOR A COUPLE YEARS THE
LAST TWO THREE YEARS. AND SO
THIS GIVES US THE OPPORTUNITY
TO MOVE FORWARD TOGETHER- OF
LABOR'S BEEN A KEY BUT A
PARTNER AT THE TABLE BY DOING
THESE BECAUSE THE DISCUSSIONS
AND CONVERSATIONS. AND I THINK
THAT- WITH OF THEIR THEIR-
DIFFERENT CLAIMS AS TO THE
DEGREE OF- MISS CLASSIFICATION.
THE DEGREE TO WHICH AN ISSUE
THE DEGREE TO WHICH THE CURRENT
MODEL WORKS FOR THE INDUSTRY-
BUT YOU KNOW AS FAR AS THE
PUBLISHERS ARE CONCERNED. LET'S
GET THAT INFORMATION SO THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY DIG A LITTLE
DEEPER. RATHER THAN- KIND OF
THE CHARADE OF DECIDING THESE
EXTENSIONS EXTENSIONS FOR
EXTENSION SAKE- I THINK WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY. DO
SOMETHING MORE MEANINGFUL WHEN
WE COME BACK- DETERMINE YOU
KNOW. BECAUSE THIS INDUSTRY IS
DIFFERENT- BUT THERE HAS TO BE
THAT RECOGNITION. PARTICULARLY
IN TERMS OF- OF WHAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING TO IT IS MOVED
TOWARDS DIGITAL AND HOW A LOT
OF PAPERS SPECIAL OF THE LOCAL
PAPERS ABOUT PAPERS DESCRIBING
BUT- AT THE SAME TIME. WE CAN'T
LOSE SIGHT OF THE WORKERS AND
THE FACT THAT THEY'RE ALSO
WORKERS ARE CAUGHT UP IN THIS
INDUSTRY. THAT MAY VERY WELL BE
TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF. AND WE
DON'T WANT THAT EITHER AND SO
WITH THAT- AGAIN EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION. THE NEWSPAPER-
THE NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION- THE LABOR
FEDERATION AND OTHERS HAVE BEEN
PART OF THE THIS. LONG BUT I
THINK IMPORTANT PROCESS BUT
THAT IS BUCKLEY US WHEN I BOTH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RESEARCHER.
VENTURA SUBSECTOR CALL PLEASE.
MOTION IS RECOMMEND AMENDMENTS
BEACON. IN KALRA. HI KALRA HI
FLORA. FLOOR I. JONES SAWYER.
J. SAWYER I. AREAS I ZERO
NUMBER SAY ARE NOT FOR. WORD I.
THE BILLS UP SIX OR ARDERN WAS
OVER. I THINK YOU. HERE OTHER.
THANK.